[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des centaines de voitures s'apprête à
bloquer les routes aux quatre coins de
la france ce mercredi entre 100 et 200
véhicules ont quitté la côte d'azur
direction la capitale d'autres départs
ont été observés depuis cherbourg
strasbourg bayonne ou encore dans les
landes ici cette cinquantaine de
manifestants venus du sud-ouest de
l'hexagone organise son convoi vers
paris ces contestataires se prépare dès
ce week end a débuté ce qu'ils appellent
le convoi de la liberté
inspiré par le modèle des camionneurs
canadien ils disent défendre leur
liberté en s'opposant à l'obligation
vaccinale ils ont en ligne de mire ce
sésame indispensable pour accéder à
certains
[Musique]
de soutenir le convoi des libertés
on a été tellement heureux de voir ce
qui se passait au canada et de voir ce
qui se passe maintenant en europe dans
le monde on vient soutenir tous ceux qui
vont partir pour une liberté et voilà il
a fallu être responsable moi je suis
allé travailler les trois confinement
j'ai attrapé le coc vide au travail et
voilà et derrière ça arrange et un héros
de la nation maintenant je suis même
plus un citoyen donc je comprends pas
comment on est passé de l'un à l'autre
le pass vaccinale a justement été
évoquée par l'exécutif ce mercredi
devant les médias à l'issue du conseil
des ministres le porte-parole du
gouvernement a laissé entendre qu'il
pourrait disparaître dès la fin du mois
de mars voire début avril il ya des
mesures qui s'applique aujourd'hui
encore dans notre pays elles sont levé
progressivement partie des mesures a été
levé 2 février notre série mesure le 16
février j'ai toujours dit s'agissant du
pass vaccinale que nous le lèveront dès
lors qu'il y aura une normalisation de
la situation à l'hôpital c'est à dire
qu'il n'y aura plus un hôpital sous très
forte tension du fait du coc vide on
constate qu'il ya un début
d'amélioration à l'hôpital et il y a le
professeur fisher à l'adie des
projections démonétisation qui peuvent
nous laisser espérer effectivement qu'à
cet horizon de fin mars début avril
cette déclaration ne semble pas remettre
en cause la mobilisation des
protestataires
plusieurs appels ont été lancés sur les
réseaux sociaux pour paralyser la
capitale dès ce samedi des dizaines de
milliers de membres ont été décomptés
dans des groupes facebook pour ce
rassemblement d'ampleur
certains se disent même prêts à rallier
bruxelles lundi prochain pour une
convergence européenne